Es war ein gigantischer vulkanausbruch
fast zwei
kubikkilometer material wollen wir ausgeworfen anderthalb mal so viel wie bei der explosion
des morgens ansatz hat 80 es entstand kein normaler kater sondern eine caldera mit einem durchmesser von viereinhalb
Kilometern doch niemand hat es mitbekommen
2012 also vor kurzem erst nur auf dem meer da trieb eine riesige insel aus bimsstein mit
400 quadratkilometern da sind 100 mehr als beim alter es geht
Um den größten vulkanausbruch unter wasser in den letzten 100 jahren jetzt hat eine expedition eine unwirtliche landschaft
In einem kilo meter wassertiefe entdeckt und die unglaublichen ausmaße dieser unterwasser katastrophe jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
Die eruption des vulkans
Im jahr 2012 ein fast unvorstellbares ereignis denn hierbei handelt
Sich wortwörtlich um einen unterwasser giganten der damals aus insgesamt
14 knoten
lavaströme herauskatapultiert
Und nicht nur dass einige lavaströme haben wohl auch größere erdrutsche zur folge gehabt doch wie heftig und komplex die eruption
Im jahr 2012 tatsächlich war hat jetzt ein forschungsteam aus australien
konkret ermitteln können erst jetzt hinweise darauf dass sich detaillierte
untersuchungen deshalb von vulkans nordöstlich von neuseeland lohnen könnten gab dem forschungsteam tatsächlich eine an ein zufallsfund
Im sommer 2012 hat nämlich flug passagiere über dem südwestpazifik eine äußerst interessante entdeckung gemacht ein
gigantisches floss aus bimsstein
unfassbare 400
quadratkilometer groß also knapp 100 quadratkilometer größer als malta der kleinste mitgliedsstaat der europäischen union
Bei
Den stein handelte sich um ein gestein das bei vulkanausbrüchen entsteht enthält so viele
Gasblasen dass es meistens stimmt wenn es sich nicht vollsaugt und da diese
Entdeckung mitten auf dem ozean weit entfernt vom nächsten land gemacht worden war stand auch gleich fest
dass dieser bimsstein vom meeresgrund stammen muss entstanden durch den ausbruch eines unterwasservulkans
durch die analyse seiner trifft richtung ergab sich dann der schluss ziemlich schnell
Das bimsstein floss bei dem ausbruch des harfe untersee vulkans entstanden sein muss er ist umgeben von einer kette aus vulkan
Da sich in diesem gebiet die pazifische unter die australische platte schiebt und die expedition des australischen forschungsteams war tatsächlich
Äußerst aufschlussreich durch einen ferngesteuerten
autonomen tauchroboter kamen sie ihren einige proben des vulkanischen materials und die auswertung der daten ja die war mehr als
Überraschend zitat als wir uns die aufzeichnung des tauchroboters an schauten sahen wir all diese
Buckel auf den meeresgrund. Ich dachte das so nah
Des roboters ist gestört so einer der beteiligten forscher dem zu doch die
Buckel so wie er es nannte stellten sich dann als gigantische bin steinbrocken heraus teilweise so groß wie
lastwagen dazu soll zitat etwas
Vergleichbares habe ich noch nie auf dem meeresgrund gesehen als das forschungsteam versuchte die brocken, zu bergen
zerbröselten diese das wiederum liegt die vermutung
Nahe dass die bams steine sehr langsam auf dem meeresgrund gesunken sein müssen denn sonst wären sie ja bereits beim prozess in sich zerfallen
und der tauchroboter liegt hatte eine zweite unglaubliche erkenntnis
insgesamt 14 schlote müssen bei der eruption
Im jahr 2012 beteiligt gewesen sein noch heute sind die erkaltete lavaströme als riesige
La wartung zu sehen bis zu 500 meter breit und 30 meter hoch doch welche konsequenzen hätte ein vulkanausbruch
ähnlichen ausmaßes anderen vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch an den ausbruch des isländischen vulkans
eyjafjallajökull
das war 2010 und die vulkanasche sorgt dafür dass in weiten teilen nord und mitteleuropas der flugverkehr
Lahmgelegt war für mehrere tage das hatte erhebliche nachteile für die wirtschaft und das große problem bleibt es ist fast unmöglich
vulkane sicher einschätzen zu können oder in den griff zu bekommen oder
Vorherzusagen wann da was passiert und das ist aber unabdingbar um die menschheit
Im worst case zu retten nämlich beim ausbruch eines vulkans
Ja wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wir dann meldet euch hierbei
Whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr nämlich vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort die
rechts in der redaktion von klicks und mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
Und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken katastrophe durch supervulkan hat nasa die lösung ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran